there really isn't much vulnerability in
the head it's your heart space yeah so
it gets you into your
from your head to the heart so it goes
right back to the longest road is from
the head to the heart
i know the song i can't remember but it
seems so short
it's so close but it's so far
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today
is a special show with my friend stacy
barnes we've been friends for
15 years and we have been known to do
plenty of deep diving together
when no one is listening but we thought
it'd be really cool to
deep dive for you guys on one word
and the word today is vulnerable this is
a really important concept
and something to something to embrace
as as a person i can't think of a way
that it would hurt you to be more
vulnerable but it is also very difficult
so we're gonna go into what that looks
like what that's looked like for us what
it means to us
and hopefully you can take something
away that will hopefully make you a
little bit more vulnerable yourself
and connect with people and connect with
situations
in a meaningful way so please enjoy one
of the hardest things to do
is to be vulnerable um and it's almost
one of the
it's like one of the hardest things to
do even if you want to do it
because it's hard to get to the deepest
layer of vulnerability like we've been
talking about so much lately it's like
if you
there's the surface projection of an
emotion of like
or projection of the deeper emotion
that's like you've done something
i'm mad at you mm-hmm but the
vulnerability
the real layer is deeper and that's that
i'm not
mad at you because you
um snapped on me i'm mad because now you
make me feel
sad you make me feel like i've done
something wrong you make me feel
insecure or something like that so like
it's the deeper layer
that is that you're it's always like the
softer one it's always the more
vulnerable it's like the sadder one
and the vulnerable one so it even shifts
from being mad
to oh wait a minute okay so the surfaces
i'm mad
but then when you go to the vulnerable
space because you just mentioned i'm sad
it's you're hurt yeah i'm hurt and it's
what's so interesting in conversation
there's a difference between mad energy
and anger and contempt and resentment
compared to
this this hurt me and and
you know and and i just i want to share
that with you and it and it makes me sad
and it makes me not feel
whole or seen or valued or worthy
whatever and so
vulnerability go takes from the surface
and it goes down to the where the real
feelings are from
i believe it takes you from the head
there really isn't much vulnerability in
the head
it's your heart space yeah so it gets
you into your from your head to the
heart so it goes right back to the
longest road
is from the head to the heart i know the
song i can't remember but it seems so
short
it's so close but it's so fun yeah
it is it is we get lost and and i think
this is
super common especially in relationships
where
we react to something we're offended so
we're like well that was shitty
and you're like okay
danica what was what were you really
feeling well what i was really feeling
was i was really feeling like i wasn't
important enough
yeah i was really feeling like you
didn't see me i was really feeling like
you were
like you don't love me enough or like
you don't care about me you're like i'm
not your
highest priority or like i'm i'm not
enough and i'm not good enough and i'm
not
this enough or that enough like those
that's really because that's really
what's going to activate the heart space
and that's where you're going to get
that's where you're going to get where
you want to go with someone whether it
be a partner or a friend
or family when you peel the layers down
to the deepest one the vulnerable one
where you can go go ahead and judge me
for
being being wimpy go ahead and judge me
for being soft go ahead and judge me for
being sad and
for crying and for all these things but
this is my truth and
but guess what if you can just practice
that vulnerability of
going to a space that feels really
uncomfortable
you're going to find somebody meets you
there well
and like energy meets like energy
yeah so typically when we speak from
our space of vulnerability which is from
our heart
not always but more than likely
when we're using those words from our
truth from the vulnerable space
it automatically activates their heart
space and if it doesn't
that's okay you just move on from that
and
sometimes when i'm in a space and i'm
having a difficult conversation with my
husband
it depends on where we're at um and if
it and if whether it's me or him
and if and if if we're feeling a little
bit of resistance sometimes we just need
to take a break and then re-address it
when we can step into that heart space
because the conversations that are not
met with the same energy right it's it
is like oil and water that does kind of
happen
sometimes it happens where somebody's
not ready to see
not ready to hold space for that emotion
true that happens and that
that's that's hurtful and that's where
you have to under you have there has to
be an understanding with your family
or your partner or your friends where
you say
you have to trust there has to be an
understanding that that emotion needs to
be honored
right that deep sad vulnerable emotion
when you feel sad about something when
you feel
you know you feel not seen you feel
unimportant you feel
you feel like you're not listened to you
feel like you're not valuable or you're
not a priority whatever it may be
that other person needs to see that
and honor that that's the only way
you're ever going to keep that kind of
conversation going
is when somebody looks at you and says
i'm so sad
sorry to make you sad i don't want you
to be sad that was never what i was
intending and that's usually the answer
right but they
they can't react to you like that's
ridiculous why are you even
why why do you even think that that's
not the space
where you're going you're exactly right
where are you going to come together
so there has to be an understanding with
vulnerability with whoever it's with
that they have to honor that right
because then you're going to grow from
there but you're never going to grow
from a space where somebody is
judging right because they don't
defending right they actually
they're not even barely probably
listening to your vulnerability because
it's
almost impossible to not connect with
the vulnerability because it's
it's from your heart yeah it's they're
thinking about the other part of it
still
and the vulnerability is something
they're they're not even listening to
yet they're not letting it resonate with
their heart
they're just thinking like but why are
you mad it's so stupid
it's dumb why would you even get mad at
that why does that even matter you're
making a big deal out of nothing
they're still stuck on that so until you
can get someone to transition into the
into the space of heart and feel and
emotion and vulnerability
you're never going to be on the same
page so sometimes that takes time
sometimes that takes and sometimes most
of the time communication doesn't always
come through words
some people write it better some people
need space to think
yes there's all kinds of ways where
people
cope and like digest information and at
different speeds too like i'm a
i'm a fast digester i'm like let's go
let's dive deep let's go
and i'm like why doesn't that why don't
you hear me why do and sometimes people
just need some time and they need their
own
they need their own their own ways right
they're in their own their own needs
your own ways to connect within
and some we're all on different paths in
our journey we're all at different
stages we're all at different levels and
elevations and so
that's when you start doing the
vulnerable work when you step into your
vulnerability and you're really doing
your
your own self-work around that um
that's where for me where i've found
levels of
deeper levels of compassion and empathy
and so if i notice
um a triggered reaction i think oh i
i once was there i came by someone else
like if someone right if someone else is
triggered by a conversation i'm having
yeah
or or something i'm yeah and it's a boom
like i can feel if it's a wall i can
feel
sure if it or if they're triggered and
so i instantly kind of go
back to the rain thing and because
because i feel that energy instantly i'm
like
i kind of i kind of pushed a button that
was not at all my intention because not
everyone wants to be vulnerable
and that's fine um but
when that happens it's that's when i
take that moment and i just step back
and then i actually feel into it and
feel is this the right time
is this right for that person i'm in
conversation with
and i just remember it's not personal
and so so it's
it's really interesting and then when
we're in relationships um
you know with my husband and i what we
learned through our therapies are the
tools to do exactly what you're talking
about which is
what's the most thing that we all want
in a relationship
yeah and it's to be heard yeah and to be
seen
in a very simple thing yeah is
where as i talk so much i go on and on
about my hurt feelings or what's going
on
okay i'm in the vulnerability i've got
it but then i kind of
vomit for 30 minutes and i lost him
five minutes into it and then so not
only is it you're in your own therapy
session
right so i'm just like it's happening
it's flowing but he can't grasp
anything because it's too much and and
whether defensiveness is coming in or or
it's just
matter of fact it's just too much at
that time what we learned
is reflecting back to each other so
saying one or two sentences
and then him reflecting that back to me
or me here is what i heard
[Music]
very hard had no idea from a place of
especially if you're in a place of
disconnect
what i found was interesting in this
process when she held the space for us
to do it
and ben and i were sitting just like
this and um
he i'm getting trying to think of an
example it was like
it really bothers me that you don't
think to take the trash out when it's
full
and my and i should say back to him just
what he said
but what i would say back was a
triggered thing for me that
you think that i'm not paying attention
or that i'm lazy
because i'm not taking the trash out but
really i'm doing other things and it's
not that i'm
and then i yeah i go into a whole other
story i'm pretty bad at
like trying to give my defense or
explanation yeah well
it's it's yeah it's just not an easy
it's not an easy place to it's it's to
be vulnerable in that space
to actually hear what the person is
bringing to the table
it's a very simple little thing but that
was something that we were and
literally she stepped in and she was
like stace
that's that's not what he said try again
ben repeat to her
it was amazing that it took probably 30
minutes of just a simple back and forth
to where i had to get in the space of
not being triggered or not feeling
because a part of my
um at that time and still always will be
but is
my self-worth and my value and what i
bring
and um not having to prove myself but
knowing and believing and that's my
stuff to do
i don't have to i don't but it's mine i
have to do it for myself
so anyways that's a tool that we use in
spaces when when we do have to go
into and have that conversation um
because
uh i definitely have seen the adverse
reaction yeah i've heard and it goes
into something totally different which
is not yeah
sometimes they're not ready the
conversation which i heard a good advice
on like how to talk about something
that's difficult is
you know asking the other person
okay look if i need to bring something
up with you when is the best time to do
that
because like because it can be you can
be offended if they don't want to talk
about it when they do but maybe it's
just not the right space
yes right like you know i'm a morning
person so if i get up and want to
address something and somebody's half
asleep
not good timing right or you know i can
address something get like get through
it aka listen to me
really quickly over here off to the side
in a group and then it's like
no that's not the time or the place so
it can also be beneficial i've heard to
like
say hey so-and-so what is the best time
for us to go through things
or what's the best way or how to address
some um
because the timing can be something that
um that's off you know that's super
valid because that also was a part of
the work that we did
like you're spot on oh literally ben
would bring up
for me it's always a good time i can go
deep at like any time
like let's go that was actually for you
yeah for me yeah
at any time yeah but for for ben yeah
it's not and he had to
she said so so how is this and when are
these conversations coming up and
kind of the morning like i wake up and
if i'm feeling something it just comes
right out
yeah and she is so transparent i can't
help it
right it just comes and so so she
you know held that space and asked ben
so for you what is that and what is what
is kind of like a no-no time and he said
before work
before we're both going into work like i
feel that
we're in an energy if we're getting
ready to hold space for other people
yeah
totally put our intention into other
things yeah to actually navigate through
this is not
before work and so and
it's that simple but i was like oh
and now i have consciousness around it
so when i do feel that
i still for myself i still need to write
down and feel what's coming through for
me but i wait
to kind of work to have a conversation
with him around it
and whatever time that is and i and i
love what you said asking and checking
in
yeah because even at night when when
he's depleted maybe that's not the right
so it's totally okay to carve out the
last thing you want to do if you're
being vulnerable
is then be also dismissed or not seen
again on an even like right you're like
here i am i'm sure
it's more of the discount even more
disconnect exactly because you're like
holy [ __ ] i'm going to go there i
finally got the guts or i or
or this is so important to me i need to
address it why isn't it
then we're projecting why isn't is it as
important to you as it is to me
right um when it might just not be that
big of a deal or the answer might be
really
simple and clear and not going to offend
you at all
so yeah to enter into that vulnerable
space
um and then to be uh rejected basically
um and not seen and not heard can be can
make matters worse
so sometimes so basically it really all
comes down to these good old-fashioned
things like
it's all about communication it is i
explain relationships like
it's like like i was saying the other
day it's like going to the doctor and
you get your clean bill of health and
you don't want to go you don't want to
go and then you finally go and you're
like oh man i feel so much better
and then all the best thing you can do
after that is go regularly so that no
matter what
happens in your life with your body if
anything comes in
that needs to be fixed you're you're
you're stage one you know what i mean
like you're
you catch it quickly it's it's usually
manageable
it's quick it's easy um then that is
like that is an easy way to catch things
and i feel like that's the same thing in
relationships
you have to if you can catch things
early enough and stop letting them build
up and stop pushing them down until the
point where it
literally just becomes part of your
personality
with your partner then you
will always keep the decks clear and
you'll always feel
this energy of being on the same page
like i feel like you hear in
relationships they're like
i don't know we're just out of sync
right now we're just we're just not like
we're just not on the same page right
now it's because your energy your
vibration
is off like someone is mad someone is
offended
someone is sad someone is like someone
is not seen
someone someone is someone is thinking
negative thoughts and so you
don't feel like you're in sync and
you're on the same page because you're
you're vibrationally not and so um i
feel like with relationships that's
really important to just like
keep up with it and look from you know
my experience in this relationship we're
extremely transparent
our our energy is like i can have
we can be standing in the kitchen
talking about something and then all of
a sudden i can like
turn the other way and not say anything
and all of a sudden he'll be like what
just happened
what's wrong what's going on and it's
like
if you can get to the point where you
feel that level of connection where you
can immediately
address something look sometimes it
means you address things frequently
but you never get to the point where you
have like these
deep down really deeply rooted problems
that are going to take a lot of time to
figure out
that's true i would say for us like it's
it's nice i don't
i don't feel like we ever and it's not a
matter of like
don't go to bed mad i believe that but
it's really because i just don't want to
stop until it's solved because it
doesn't feel good though i don't know
like energetically it's like oh it's
horrible like bad sleep like every now
and again it happens but then
you know but i really just have such a
deep motivation to
solve yeah the the the the
difference or the lack of understanding
or the
or whatever's going on i really really
really want to solve it
and so um so it's not like i don't i
don't use that rule like don't go to bed
mad it's just because i'm so damn
motivated to figure it out
that i i'm still awake because it's
still today um
so uh so yeah i i feel like we don't
ever get to that point where we
go to sleep without having that
understanding if we've ever had if we
have an issue
where we look at each other i love you
like i'm i'm like i understand
okay i understand okay i'll work on that
okay i'll work on that
and then you move forward but i think
that there are so many relationships
that basically and this is this is
this is like the fundamentals of
relationships to me there's three kinds
one you grow apart two
one grows and one doesn't three you grow
together
so the only way you can grow together is
if you are
on the same page if you are on the same
frequency
and if you are communicating which is
going to mean
you're going to have to be vulnerable
but not vulnerable from a simple
standpoint of like
well that makes me mad well you know
what i'm really
pissed when you do this or um that's not
fair
or whatever it's it's the deeper one
where
it's the it's the sad part the sad one
if you don't get to the sad one the hurt
one you're not moving now that you're
not going deep enough
yeah okay gotta get a little deeper yeah
i agree
well let's hope that uh let's hope that
this is some kind of insight into
you know just how it feels because it's
like it's the most
important element in my opinion to
um deep connections i completely agree
and i think your intention around this
was to share in a space
that we're all going through [ __ ] yeah
not doesn't mean it's bad but it doesn't
always feel good and you're opening up
the space that
you're not alone and this is a part of
the journey and i think that that's very
this is huge for you it's very
vulnerable for you and i think it's a
beautiful thing that you're offering
and um it's it's incredible yeah so
thank you here's to uh here's to crying
oh here's to lots of vulnerability so it
doesn't have to be sad
yeah thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today i hope
you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you